hey guys everybody on the VIP continuing
the original content theme which I think
has been really driving my email
newsletter so thanks for watching thanks
for listening and here's a your little
exclusive piece of content anchor a new
audio social network app has made some
noise this week I've been enjoying it it
is a super interesting here it is a lot
of people starting to follow me which is
fun just put out kind of memos to the
world voice Twitter i think is not super
inappropriate something I've been
watching and hoping to happen for a long
time I like voice but more importantly
here's what I want to talk about much
like I'm watching everybody on snapchat
now sell $300 ebooks or change their
profiles to snapchat QR codes or all the
other things it keeps doing that one of
the things that I've noticed in facebook
and in twitter facebook fanpages twitter
tumblr Instagram snapchat musically and
now the potential and anchor the upside
of being an early mover meerkat I've
seen Brian social you know all these
people like meerkat periscope the
advantage of being the first users on a
new platform and being loud and proud
and using your other social networks to
bring awareness to you being on there
your newsletters your other means word
of mouth email however you want to go
about it and I'm really learning the
craft putting out content being part of
the community following other people
engaging with them responding to them
that is a blueprint that works now for
every Instagram there is a clerk there
is a social cam but when I look at the
first 10 15 pioneers on vine or the
first 500 on and swim or the first
hundred on musically there's such a
disproportionate advantage to be an
early influence or personality on one of
these platforms that you can miss eight
times in a row and that ninth one will
pay out the ROI of all your efforts and
tribulations if you have enough talent
in the communication of the medium that
you choose if you were scared of video
and you're not a great writer but you
can talk a little anchor if it clicks
and go
us and right now it is so far from that
I don't predict it will I don't even
think it will but but if it does the
punchline of this video is I do not
think yeah actually I'll go a different
way I believe it is in your best best
and interest on every peach and every
anchor to move fast to be part of the
community and to try to build your brand
in the first 60 days on the platform
because if one of them does become
Twitter or Pinterest or vine it will
change your life